and so now here's the way it shakes out
um
with the as we pointed out dallas losing
the tiebreaker to portland though their
records are identical portland still
holds the number six spot
hey ernie yes can we put the lakers
schedule up
i would hate you know i can give you the
lakers okay go ahead they play dallas
next
okay yes they've got dallas next and
then there and then
at orlando and at washington
home against sacramento home against
toronto home against denver
okay they're safe they're safe then and
then they go to the clippers they go to
portland and they're home with the suns
home with the knicks home with the
rockets that three spot is not a good at
indiana and
no but i'm saying i was because because
they got some games coming up they can
win because they could actually drop to
the play-ins
i know it's only two on the lost side
yeah but but but they're going to
orlando
washington washington's playing
washington's playing well right now and
i'll tell you what i've told you already
none of those teams in the eastern
conference
want to see the wizards with russ and
bradley
yeah in the playoffs i was looking at
the other day that
they'd beat in brooklyn a couple of
times well
they're in the play-in situation
possibly yeah yeah well right now they
are they gonna win
well yeah i mean they're the only ones
they're gonna win half a game ahead
but they're gonna win the play-in i love
russ and bradley bill
to me i i i'd pay to watch russell
westbrook play basketball
he and bradley bill yes there's not many
guys in the league
but the question i have ernie is like
if you're the three spot and you're the
clippers i don't know how safe the three
spot is
because you have to either play portland
or dallas i'm not sure if that's a safe
bet we'll be in that position you know
those teams scare you
yeah i would say both we because dame
lillard which would definitely should
scare you
and luca donna should definitely scare
you because those two guys are really
clippers got the best record in the
league since the all-star break yeah
right now they are no they're they've
been they've been playing well and i
think getting just
getting the two is important for them
all right i think the
key to me is we have given the jazz no
respect i'm gonna stop
doing why because not a single person
i've heard
on this show on any other show said in
jazz
they've had the best record for the last
six months in the nba
okay where do you think they're ceiling
is that
i think the utah jazz can win the
championship the whole thing the whole
thing
kenny they got the coach of the year
they got two all-stars are you
convincing me are you telling me i got
the sixth man of the year you got the
sixth man of the year
i'm telling you uh i remember last year
they got
job because bogdanovic didn't play the
playoff they would have beat denver last
year
if bogdanovic had a play the only reason
you know
i don't know how shaq feels but proven
commodities
you know usually win in the league
that's that's all so it hasn't been a
proven commodity
typically i have never i just haven't
seen it unless it's an assembled
assembly of superstar players teams come
out of nowhere
and win the championship they're very
good they have not taken those steps
lose it this year and win it next year
possibly they had a great season last
year
yeah but that that that's the step they
love they lost
so what wouldn't having the best work in
the league this year be the next that's
the next step
and then i think you win it the next
step after that
is to make it past the second round
right next door yeah they haven't
they've lost in the first round knocked
out in the first round their last two
yeah but i guarantee you that won't
happen this year
you go from not getting first round
knockout to the championship yeah no
come on
chuck that's that's that's the holdup
that's a good point though kenny proven
commodity
yeah 2007
for utah